So for me, the reason why I even come into
this field of data science is my passion for something specific,
which is natural language. Right, so I, and it, I
observe the people who work around me who knows about data
science. I think one thing that's very important is they
either have, like, a passion for the particular data they're looking
at. Like, you know, natural language, or like speech recognition kind
of data. Or some people are just very interested in patterns
in data. Like when they see some kind of some, data they
would just like, try to calculate you know, like the mean of
the data, the variance of data. They, they, it comes natural to
them because they want to find patterns to the data. So I think
for anyone who wants to become a data scientist, it's good to
think about, what kind of data you are interested in doing, and
start with that. And then later on when you have this skill
of analyzing data, you can apply it to any other kind of thing.